oh my gosh yeah that's horrible you
can't use Photoshop he's right here you
can't just photoshop your head on top of
mine what's up laughs Bob oh I'm
Chadwick Boseman it's Michael B Jordan
and you guys sitting in superhero picks
and I'm gonna read them all right so
first up we got the flash add star one
two three all right cool yeah that's
horrible yeah that's pretty bad
flash nope nope nope nope Catherine
Coleman that does not look like a
superhero but I'm interested I don't
know which one's Catherine I think
that's a cat suit all right yeah I like
it I see that see the claws black white
panther yes oh right a man should never
wear ballet shoes and that's not bad
they shoes we should never look like
that ever you just bored bro I don't
even know like what the tutu is
spider-man like I don't know who put
those together like bad idea
Matthew zero nine eight points for
originality what does that say puffs is
that that was that oh oh uff what is
that I don't this start this again is
that that's Amber Rose that is not M
Rose that's really ever Rose Amber Rose
yeah I'm good and skip down to it's
actually okay but you know I think you
need a better tattoo artist Joker
okay yeah see that yeah I mean you know
work out bro you live protein so I I
don't know what that is I don't know
what you are
nice try nice try
that's not the way you dress up your dog
man is that supposed to be Captain
America
the dog looks so uncomfortable like yeah
I know my parents are weird
look you've given
yeah no help you can't use Photoshop
okay cool I see man yeah I see Photoshop
is real Photoshop is really yeah of
course
yeah yeah that's right he's he's right
here you can't just photoshop your head
on top of mine yeah I don't even know
the picture on the left like why like I
don't even know why that one's even in
there like wow I gotta say you've been
working out there shaved the beard
though Clark Kent
so you did a great job sitting there man
next time find a better store to buy
your costumes from and do not Photoshop
your hair like and replace of mine at
birth